in our series I on earth we're learning
what hundreds of years of natural
history can teach us about the problems
we face today London's Royal Botanic
Gardens are home to more than 50
thousand living plants and more than 7
million plant species including some
collected by Charles Darwin himself on
this 50th anniversary of Earth Day many
of us will not get outside to enjoy any
of nature so Mark Phillips reports from
a backyard that's like no other if you
had to choose a place to self isolate
during this koban virus crisis you could
do worse than here these are the Royal
Botanical Gardens at Kew in West London
a place where they've been studying the
health of the planet for about 250 years
and never has their work seen more vital
than now it's not a bad backyard that
you come here it's exceptionally
beautiful but it's tragic to see these
beautiful gardens 330 acres here at Kew
a world heritage site to see them empty
normally there would be ten or twelve
thousand people strolling about Kew
Gardens on a glorious spring day like
this but in the post virus world there's
only us
Richard devrel is the director of Kew
Gardens and actually lives on the
property not a bad perk do you see a
relationship between what's going on now
the Hulk Ovid 19 crisis that the world
is experiencing and the kinds of things
the queue has been trying to do for the
centuries I think humanity faces some
really fundamental challenges unless we
start to treat the natural world better
but is there anything about the current
situation that makes you think the
lesson may in fact finally hit home I
don't know but I hope so I hope that we
will listen to scientists and experts
more carefully both the politicians and
the public and I hope too that we'll
realize that actually the cost of
pre-empting a problem of mitigating it
is a fraction of the cost of dealing
with it when it engulfs you Kew Gardens
is not just a pretty place it's been a
research centre - going way back
parcels of specimens arrive every week
from scientific workers and collectors
all over the world and over the years
they've learned one thing if you abused
the natural world bad things happen
including bad things to people but if
you treat the world with respect it pays
you back and at the simplest level of
course plants provide us with oxygen
they provide us with rainfall for our
crops they provide us with food about a
quarter of all cancer medicines derived
from plants and fungi so they deliver
many many beneficial things to humans
not that they're above a little
tinkering with nature here trying to
help plants cope with the warming world
right now among others its coffee a crop
that is threatened as we found out in
the hills of Uganda not long ago not
enough rain too much sunshine bad fruit
yes to make sense any producers buddy
fruit seen at cue they're trying to find
varieties that are more tolerant perhaps
some have greater heat tolerance or
aridity tolerance that can be bred into
the commercial crop to safeguard future
supply of coffee but this is also a time
for deeper thoughts what happens once
this current crisis is over we've got a
situation today where four and a half
billion people are in lockdown that's
extraordinary so I hope if nothing else
this kovat experience has given us a
dose of humility actually we are just
one species of many many millions and we
need to play our role alongside those
other species in a responsible way and
you've got a beautiful place to sit
around and think about it I suddenly do
Kew Gardens has always been a place
where beauty and science meet and like
all parks it's a place for quiet
reflection never quieter than now for
CBS this morning I'm Mark Phillips in
Kew Gardens London that's a great piece
there by mark and Anthony when I think
about the 50th anniversary of Earth Day
I think that 50 years ago there was
still an idea out there that we humans
couldn't really influence the earth that
it was so big so vast that it was
invulnerable now one of the triumphs of
Earth Day is that we all recognize that
we
a role to play in stewardship just like
we managed Kew Gardens there's a degree
of management we all have to do with
protecting this earth role on that's
right and it's it's what we've seen in
the last few weeks is just how much of
an impact we have we seen the air
quality suddenly improve when we stopped
driving I mean it's it's it's in our
control if we take it